this blend as payloaders around two
thousand pounds it has 16 solar panels a
weather balloon gets the temperature the
air pressure the wind speed and so forth
why would you need 16 solar panels said
to be said to be three buses across very
very large much bigger than a weather
balloon my name is Dr Andrew Harmon and
I'm going to debunk some spy blind
theories for Wired
and the world of intelligence and
Espionage almost anything is possible
but is highly unlikely that this was a
rather bloke that's quite interesting
the flight path that this took it left
from the island of Hainan in the south
of China it drifted across the country
it goes over important Air Force bases
and Montana and Nebraska Missouri until
they got to South Carolina and it was
shot down he got it
got it
could be a coincidence that it went over
an important base that has
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
intelligence and Espionage sometimes
those coincidences quite often there's
not
one of the other explanations out there
is that this is a practice one for a
future military attack attaching up a
bomb to a balloon it's not a particular
effective means to wage Modern Warfare
you've got planes you've got missiles
that can be fired from One content to
another why put it on a blend that's
very slow moving doesn't make any sense
often when you want to attack somebody
you probe their defenses you can even
think about this if you watch two boxers
that are probing each other where are
they weak there's an entity called NORAD
n-o-r-a-d this is the defense of the
environment around North America if
you're thinking about this as an
outsider what a great way to test NORAD
to see how effective they are to see
what they pick up on
think the amount of mental gymnastics
that you'd have to do to make this a UFO
based explanation would be incredible
let's just go with a simple one Cheney
said it's theirs it's a Chinese blend
came over the United States it was shot
down look for the simplest possible
explanation
there's a common misconception that
balloons have never been used for
intelligence purposes before blinds
starts off 1794 the Battle of fleurs and
the French Revolutionary Wars fast
forward the Civil War Lincoln's worried
that Washington could be captured with a
potentially devastating effect on morale
in the north they're used to try to make
sure that Washington is not captured
that is not surprised we're also used in
the second world war as an obstacle over
London to try to disrupt German bombers
during the Blitz the Cold War there's
various Bloom programs United States for
example had a program project Moby Dick
1956 to send balloons up over the Soviet
Union to try to get a picture of what
they were up to
[Music]
can they see inside your house they
probably could I guess the question is
why would they want to they may be
interested in what the vice president's
up to they're not going to be interested
in what the average person is up to you
can get incredible resolution say this
is someone that you stippy and the Royal
Air Force and he used to spend time
looking at aerial reconnaissance images
I've heard that the resolution it can
capture up to 10 centimeters from that
height of six to thousand feet that's
probably what military Nations State
satellites can capture other things we
can think about as what can it hear what
kind of communications are being sent
that the blunt can pack up human
language or encrypted human language
another one that's often overlooked is
what we call measurements and signature
intelligence what can you smell what can
you detect and the atmosphere gases
Vapors particles dust 1949 the silver
Union detonates the nuclear weapon the
stunning mule sure has the atom bomb and
has exported it they've used information
intelligence from people that they had
inside the Manhattan Project built their
own bomb and the Detonator how did the
United States find out about it it was
the detection of nuclear particles in
the air that's how they knew the Soviets
had the bomb
this is quite common in the history of
intelligence and Espionage you where you
watch who are they speaking to her other
contacts is this a spy ring or is it
just one person this is something that
investigators intelligence analysts
mohunters do all the time the more you
let it go on the more you can see the
tentacles of the Espionage it's
something that happens every day and
international politics is part of the
world around us maybe you don't see it
but it's taking place almost everywhere